so Jonathan majors has officially been
found guilty in court and Marvel Studios
has officially fired Jonathan Majors we
pretty much knew that this was going to
happen if he was found guilty Marvel
Studios pretty much didn't have a choice
despite only being charged with two out
of the four charges against him he was
still fired by Marvel Studios and
everybody is reporting about that today
the Rolling Stone Hollywood Reporter
deadline variety this is official
Jonathan Majors will no longer play Kang
the Conqueror in the MCU and now it
looks like Marvel Studios might be
scrapping Kang alog together now a
studio rep for Marvel Studios and Disney
did confirm the news about their
decision to fire Jonathan Majors so
again as official as it gets and now
Outlets are reporting that Avengers King
Dynasty is most likely not avengers King
Dynasty anymore and this would
completely change the course that Marvel
Studios is on right now now we had heard
reports about this in the the past Jeff
lovess was originally supposed to be
writing Avengers King Dynasty but he was
removed from the project Michael Waldren
was put on the project but we heard when
he went into the project it was no
longer titled King Dynasty but simply
titled Avengers 5 now at the time some
Outlets were reporting that this was
kind of a precaution by Marvel Studios
that the decision wasn't fully made yet
to completely get rid of Kang in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe nevertheless a
lot of reports started coming out
stating that perhaps Dr Doom could take
his spot because according to a report
from variety when Marvel Studios did
their recent Retreat instead of it being
happy and full of fun and full of energy
this time it was a little bit different
considering the state of the MCU and
Jonathan major his future was one of the
main topics what do you do if Jonathan
major is found guilty they decided to
fire him and it's very clear that they
decided that if he was found guilty they
would instantly fire him it's very clear
that this was decided long ago because
not long after the news came out today
that he was found guilty the studio
confirmed that he was gone so they had
this plan in place before which leads us
to believe that they have a backup plan
and that backup plan is reportedly en
rumored I say both because at this point
in time who really knows what Marvel's
thinking but the reports before were
that they were going to move away from
the character and possibly introduce Dr
Doom and Marvel pretty much only has two
choices in this matter since they have
officially fired Jonathan Majors their
two choices are simply recast the
Conqueror get a different actor to play
him which I thought would have been the
most logical thing to do or they could
simply remove the villain all together
which seems a bit odd now that he's been
set up in such a big way especially with
the post credit for Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania and not to mention the
first and second season of Loki they set
him up in a huge way but Loki is now
kind of the master of the Multiverse
he's holding it all together and there
were reports that have been out for a
long time now since this first happened
in March insiders were coming out
stating that Marvel Studios kind of has
a backup plan with Loki for season 2 in
case they have to fire Jonathan majors
and now we are seeing this all come to
fruition I believe it was Alex P over at
the cosmic circus who first reported
this stating that the end of Loki season
2 will kind of make it to where Marvel
could go either way continue on with
Kang or get rid of Kang so basically
Loki is now pretty much the controller
of the Multiverse he holds it together
whereas King the Conqueror he who
remains he ruled over it before kept the
sacred timeline but now Loki is in
charge and he's given us a true
Multiverse and that's where the new
story could come into play I don't think
at least I really hope not they would be
foolish to do this I don't think they
are going to get rid of The Saga being
the Multiverse Saga after all Deadpool 3
is already in place the Multiverse is
already in place they can't really Veer
from that now they can Veer away from
Kang and he who remains in his variants
but you really can't Veer away from the
multi for Saga right now especially with
aveng Secret Wars coming up but moving
forward it's pretty easy to tell a story
without K the Conqueror thanks to the
ending of Loki season 2 they'll have to
backtrack a little bit but it'll all
make sense especially since Ant-Man and
the WASP quantam Mania came out before
the ending of Loki season 2 because two
major things happened one of course is
Loki he now holds the Multiverse
together he can see everything going on
inside of the Multiverse and he allows
the Multiverse to exist now now this was
pretty clever on Marvel's behalf if they
planned it if not then it sure worked
out well for them because if Kang was
still here if Jonathan major was found
not guilty they probably wouldn't have
fired him because there would be no
rights to fire him if he didn't do
anything wrong so they'd stick with
Jonathan major as Kang and Kang would
still be the main villain and since Loki
truly opened up the Multiverse that
allows all of these different variants
of Kang to exist and then some of them
or a lot of them thousands of them like
we saw in the post credit from Quantum
Mania get loose and start teaming up
together and try to take over the
Multiverse that's how it could have been
but the end also set up something
completely opposite in the ending we saw
the TVA show us that their sole job now
is to monitor Kang variants that's
extremely convenient on Marvel's behalf
cuz now all you have to do is say hey
the TVA does their job just like they
did before just like they kept all of
the other Branch timelines from breaking
out and the Multiverse from happening
they do an extremely good job at finding
Kang variants and pruning them they're
not pruning timelines but specifically
pruning Kang variants and it even worked
out that they even showed in the file at
the end Kang from Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania and they said they had a
problem in Earth 616 but they took care
of it Ant-Man took care of it so right
there that is Marvel's way of saying hey
we're moving on from King why well
because the TVA is doing such a good job
at pruning all of the Kings he's not a
threat with Loki being able to see into
different timelines in the whole entire
Multiverse and the TVA inspecting the
Multiverse as well they put Kang on lock
down he's not a threat however you can
still say somebody body like Victor Von
Doom has gotten a hold of Kang
technology and now he is the threat to
the entire Multiverse and in a weird way
if this is what happens we basically
have a comic accurate Avengers Secret
Wars where Doom is essentially the main
villain now rumor had it before from
some insiders that there was going to be
a variant of Kang that was going to be
the beyonder well in the comics Dr Doom
takes the power of the beyonder and
becomes so powerful he becomes God
Emperor Doom so now we're set up for
this to actually be a reality and here's
the deal you can still have a beyonder
king variant but what Marvel Studios
would have to do is they would have to
introduce Dr Doom pretty soon we need a
big bad and we want to be introduced to
that big bad and have that connectivity
leading up to Secret Wars now Thanos was
built up for years and years and years
we don't have that much time now until
Avengers Secret Wars however if they
delay it till 2028 which unfortunately
thanks to this it looks like that might
be more of a possibility we could have
four 4 years so four years to make Doom
a prominent character in the MCU and all
Marvel has to do is really show a
variant of Kang it could be the beyonder
king or somebody else and have Dr Doom
run into him and take his technology and
in the comics they're actually believed
to be related so they could play off of
that as well in the MCU have a universe
to where doom and King know each other
and doom being the villain that he is
stabs him in the back and takes his
technology and ultimately he could take
over the Multiverse one Universe at a
time just like Kang did after all Kang
was just a man that worked out for
Marvel stud as well Kang is nothing
special except for his mind his
technology that he has created other
than that he's just a regular human
being but with doom he is actually a
sorcerer he's still a human but he has
incredible Godlike powers on his own
without the technology so now you add
that plus the tech Doom who is already
one of the greatest villains in history
ever out there could be one of the
greatest villains ever on screen this
could be bigger than Thanos if Marvel
Studios acts quickly and gets it done
right but let me know your thoughts
about that in the comments down below if
what everybody is saying is true and
Marvel is no longer doing Kang Dynasty
and moving away from Kang would you like
it to be doom and if so would you like
to see him take Kang technology and
obviously it would be a different person
who would play Kang for a little quick
cameo in the MCU let us know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below please don't forget to like the
video and subscribe to stay up to date
on the MCU and if you subscribe and
leave a comment down below you're
automatically entered in our giveaway
for chance to win a PS5 and Xbox series
X some marvelous Legends items and some
DC items as well the winner picks one
item and we pick one winner at the end
of each month as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof